[Music]
the VW Beetle sold over 21 and a half
million units during its record-breaking
65 year history the very last beetle
rolled off the production line of VW s
plant and Puebla Mexico in 2003
indisputably this is the cult car from
Germany
[Music]
come on Isaac the first prototypes
appeared in 1935 explains our car man
closed off but the Second World War cut
short plans for mass production that
finally got underway in 1945 the
starting year of an amazing success
story wouldn't help the folks in the
city but this beetle was no mass
production model it was one of just ten
built by hand not in Wolfsburg or Mexico
but in Switzerland this extremely rare
species of beetle goes by the name
Volkswagen boiler pickup it came to life
in 1950
[Music]
let's lighten babies Gustav says after
the war German industry was at rock
bottom people had to improvise and work
with whatever they had what they had was
the beetle so someone got the idea of
using the dependable VW as the basis for
a van what every transporter needs is a
cargo bed mounting this rather bulky
component on the rounded rear of the
beetle in a half way elegant manner
required an artistic touch Swiss coach
builder boiler was up to the task in
addition to the Volkswagen pickup boiler
also made small station wagons based on
the beetle this pickup can carry a load
of up to 380 kilograms the weight of
another five passengers but with its 25
horsepower Christoph isn't too sure
whether can get going at all
[Music]
there wasn't mrs. boylar have its roots
in the construction of fancy sports
coupe a's and convertibles it was a
design house liked by tony giugiaro and
pnina Farina so when it was asked to
build a commercial vehicle and added a
touch of elegance the split rear window
was replaced by a single rectangle but
look how this cargo platform Nestle's on
this shapely rear and then there's still
a canvas sunroof it's as luxurious as a
pickup can get though I was born in the
Swiss town of tune there is no denying
this Beatles heritage the striking rear
with the iconic split oval window had to
give way to the loading area thanks to
their good connections brothers amst and
flits boiler received the basic body
shells direct from VW's German Factory
[Music]
the delicate two spokes steering wheel
and all kinds of chrome embellishments
show these beetles were really the more
expensive export version
let's see here in the back is the
legendary VW boxer engine with 1.1 liter
displacement and 18 kilowatts of power
I'd really like to show it but that's
not easy because you have to unhook the
cover here and squeeze he wonders how
another three hundred eighty kilograms
would affect the car with so much weight
on the rear axle already with the front
wheels stay on the road you could hardly
have wish for a better commercial
vehicle engine worldwide the air-cooled
and unpretentious VW boxer enjoyed a
reputation of absolute reliability
you'll probably never see the beetle
pickup on public roads the German Swiss
project came to an end after only a few
were built says the Volkswagen boiler
pickup soon got some tough competition
from within its own ranks in 1952 a
flatbed version of the VW bus went on
the market it could haul 900 kilos and
cost less than the hand-built Beetle
pickup so it's no wonder that just under
a dozen of these were produced and
boiler itself used the first five star
killer stuff the reason was simple the
price of eight thousand Swiss francs was
out of reach of most small businesses in
1950 even if it was a commercial flop
the concept of the VW boiler pickup was
groundbreaking
[ __ ] [ __ ] Christophe says the Volkswagen
boiler pickup is an impressive example
of the VW beetles versatility who'd have
thought that a Swiss coach builder could
transform this little car into a
bonafide workhorse it also set a shining
example for later small delivery vans
from VW such as the Frida lien which all
mail bags in Germany for decades it's
clear the Volkswagen boiler pickup is a
milestone and automotive history because
it's so rare the VW boiler pickup is
much more expensive today than in the
early 1950s these days early and exotic
beetles have a big following
[Music]